Hello there, how are you doing today?
My name is Elena Felicci, and I'm a content presenter
for Epic Games.
It's really nice meeting you.
So in this course, we'll dive deep
into materials, translucency, and effects,
which I think you might have guessed already from the title.
First, we will learn how to create a translucent material
from scratch, understanding how these type of nodes
really work under the hood, together
with exploring different methods to customize them
to our liking.
Then we will cover two-sided materials
by developing a foliage material from the ground up.
And we will conclude with creating a dissolve effect
in the engine.
All right, are you ready?
Because in the next video, we'll get an overview
of our agenda for the upcoming lessons,
as well as building our first translucent material.
Let's get right into it.